if you're not proactive you could end up
with a charlie brown christmas tree this
year the dreaded supply chain issues
that we keep on talking about are also
coming for the iconic annual christmas
tree so industry experts say prices are
up and lines are already starting and
we're gonna discuss the supply chain
issues coming for christmas trees now
mac welcome to quick take tell me how
customers are doing so far does it seem
like they've gotten the hint on the
supply chain issues are you already
seeing more orders than you have in
previous years from proactive consumers
medicines kind of a bifurcation we saw
our really into christmas shoppers get
the message they bought early sales were
up across the industry in june in july
and august september but now that we've
gotten into the core kind of our super
bowl of sales for christmas decor we've
actually seen it slow down a little bit
so kind of the casual decorator i'm not
sure they're aware of the shortages and
the increased prices and the challenges
so we're going to see how it goes we've
got 20 days left of peak decor shopping
season so just a quick fact check people
are buying christmas trees in june
is what you're telling oh yes christmas
christmas christmas in july is the big
one i know that's hard to believe but if
you are a super hardcore christmas
decorator it starts in june july and
then it just keeps getting busier every
day i had no idea until i got into the
christmas space i think i was on the
casual side originally but it is a thing
and we actually saw like last year as an
example in covid then in june it really
started to tick up and so we see that
every year
but this year it was really up and then
in the last few weeks it's just been a
little slow i think many of us aren't
thinking about christmas yet right right
i mean it's also been so warm out i feel
like i i haven't thought about christmas
much at all which also brings me to the
topic of climate change i'm curious to
what extent the impact on real christmas
trees might come into play with your
consumer base you you mainly do
artificial trees if i understand
correctly do you think that you'll see
more interest because of climate
change's impact on the availability of
real christmas trees
well at the end of the day i think
consumers should feel great about having
either type of christmas tree and from
my perspective not only do we sell
artificial christmas trees but we sell
all the christmas tree trimmings at
balsam hill so ornaments trees all those
kinds of things so we love both kinds
what i think is a real challenge for the
christmas tree farmers isn't necessarily
this year with some of the impacts of
climate change that we're seeing as well
as these fires on the west coast that
actually is going to impact in eight to
ten years and the reason is that
christmas trees are pretty hearty crop
but when they're young when they just
get planted and they're typically grown
in a nursery and planted at two years
when those that money goes in the ground
for the farmers if it's a tough year if
it's a drought year
that's where it hurts and so the crops
that were lost this year are largely
crops that weren't going to produce
revenue for them for another eight
seasons and you know christmas trees are
grown in land that's not good for much
else they're not generally irrigated and
so when it's a drought it's really tough
so i think we're going to see these
impacts but they're going to mostly be
you know five to ten years away of the
last few years of droughts that have
taken out some of these younger crops
right and as we were discussing some
consumers are having trouble even
planning for a month from now much less
10 years from now but but given what you
just mentioned is that an argument for
going the artificial route and in that
case what are the prices looking like
this holiday season because of supply
chain issues have you had to raise your
prices have you had discussions about
that
we have had to raise our prices the main
issue that we've raised prices is due to
the supply chain crunch with ocean
shipping we're paying 40 million dollars
extra as a company to bring our product
in this year in both ocean shipping
rates and in fines so we've had to pass
some of that on to the consumer we hate
to do that but we also have to we're a
business we have to stay in business
that said though if you think about an
artificial tree the average artificial
tree is used for 10 years and so and
then actually after that it tends to be
passed on to someone else and so these
trees are a great investment and so i
think that when consumers come down to
it you know they say some of the
certainties in life are death and taxes
well christmas is a certainty also for
people who celebrate it and so when
consumers are looking at making that
investment i think even with the
slightly increased prices it's still or
significantly increased prices it's
still a great investment because you're
going to amortize that over 10 years and
you know that said though i think that
the reason that most consumers and it's
80 percent now of american households
that celebrate christmas with christmas
trees have an artificial tree i know
that seems like a really high number i
think the reason it's so high is not
only because it's a great investment but
also because of the convenience the big
thing being they're pre-lit you can keep
them up in your home longer we tend to
celebrate christmas now we set the trees
up before thanksgiving or this
thanksgiving weekend we take them down
after new year's and that's a really
long time to leave a live tree in your
home and so i think that's what's been
driving artificial trees but i do think
that this you know the increased prices
hopefully are still justified to the
consumer because they know they're going
to get many seasons of enjoyment out of
that tree yeah yeah something that makes
me feel potentially less likely to go
the artificial route is that i live in
new york city in a tiny apartment i
don't necessarily have anywhere to store
an artificial tree except for under my
bed which is where i put all of my shoes
so that space is already
that real estate is occupied by a really
important product already but i'm
curious do you think that uh the kind of
flight we've seen of people moving out
of big cities might impact your business
at all as well do you see people you
know potentially the bankers who all
move down to austin texas uh getting
their first artificial tree perhaps this
holiday season
well it's funny first of all we have a
tree for you we have a flat back tree
which is a tree that's cut in half this
way and you can put it up against the
wall it's kind of an optical illusion
and you might be able to slide it under
the bed if you could possibly part with
some of the shoes but that's good to
know
just for you but no you're absolutely
right we expected demand to be really
high this year for trees for two reasons
one we couldn't fulfill all the un the
demand we had last year so we were
hoping that carried over and then two i
mean who doesn't know someone that's
moved to the suburbs or move somewhere
with more space so we're thinking a lot
of people are going to buy bigger trees
this year they're going to go from a six
foot tree to a seven foot tree or seven
and a half foot tree to a 12 foot tree
in austin texas and so we are seeing
that but again the people who are super
into christmas have made those purchases
we believe and it's kind of the ones
that this is not you know
living for christmas isn't their number
one thing in life they just haven't
gotten there yet so we're gonna see over
the next two weeks really what's
happening i will say we made a rookie
move we opened a store in dallas texas
this year and we forgot to send more big
trees and so we ran out of big trees
early who doesn't know that texas needs
big trees but we made that mistake the
trees have gotten there and so that
store's doing really well but there's no
question that the influx of people to
places like texas are driving the sales
for larger trees yeah i mean we're half
joking about it but it's true that the
geography here really has an impact like
you were saying big trees in dallas uh
the flat flat-backed tree here in
manhattan um in our final minute
together mac what is your
quick advice your quick take advice for
consumers do they need to get this tree
today
i think for any holiday decor that
you're looking for it's time to shop and
the reason is we're waiting every day we
have 10 more 20 more containers coming
in with products we really want but
what's most of what's in is in and so in
the next two weeks if it's not here it's
going to be too late so i think if you
find something i'd buy it because there
isn't necessarily the replenishment
stock coming out to retail stores from
distribution centers or sitting in our
balsam hill warehouses so i've been
advising people to wait a little bit and
now we've hit the period of time where
it's like the next week or so is the
peak shopping week if it's available i'd
buy it now all right matt great advice
and hopefully uh the christmas
celebrators can listen to that and get
their decorations now while they can